i was talking about sound garden too how
you said you'd be the front man for uh
sound garden but
you don't know i wasn't trying to be
presumptuous i was just trying to be
um helpful well it's true i love sound
gardens so much and i love chris carnell
and i love um kim and matt and ben um
and just i feel so connected to them you
know just being from seattle and every
time i sing with them and the twins come
um and play in the band too it just
feels like heaven it just clicks so i
just hope he can do more some days all
do those dudes are they open to it or uh
what's the what's the deal totally oh
wow i'm totally open to it god we get
together and it never ends
yeah i've seen you do some of the sound
garden stuff it's just amazing
who was the person that didn't show up
when you ended up singing black hole son
listen i don't know so you can't quote
me on it but i have a feeling it was it
was axl rose
oh
so axel was supposed to be black hole
son from
the crew
so so you're there doing the sound
garden the whole chris cornell tribute
thing you're doing your song and all of
a sudden axel rose who's notoriously
late and you know he doesn't show up to
do black hole sun which he would have
done a nice job with that i bet really
good job yeah it makes perfect sense
when you think about it vocally and i
don't know what happened um you know of
course all i knew is that i got to do it
and it was you said you go hey
i know all the words to the song i'm
going to do it
i said i know all the words of the song
by heart i want to do it and can the
twins come and do be the guys that go
black hole son black hole son
in the background because i just knew
like they would get such a thrill out of
being on stage with those fellas
and we stayed up until four o'clock in
the morning that night thinking that
nothing was ever going to get better in
our careers than that moment and then we
wound up getting to record it and play
with them and all this [ __ ] is so
surreal